complete Kevin's Twitter bio my name is
Kevin Hart and I am a piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
hey you don't I'm Kevin Hart aka K Hart
aka the real deal
aka that guy Dwayne Johnson here aka the
rock aka la rocca aka that guy my name
is Dwayne the rock Johnson
alright well we got here okay we got all
the shows shot we got set right here and
a time it takes the dog to climb one
step named for chocolate bars Snickers
KitKat's Mars oh [ __ ] [ __ ] according to
google how tall is kept
okay this is good
according to google google yes okay is
this the legit answer because I know it
or is this do i [ __ ] with you on this
which one go I think you should go for
what you know well go for what I know
the JIT answered legit legit legit
because I know you're my best friend
forefoot - yes no come on okay okay got
five six five five no five four five
four but in in in centimeters within my
centimeters thirty to one point six two
one centimeters tall well uh what what
would what type of what type of person
are you in school were you uh you know
before you jock huh
ladies man with nerd which one class now
how's Glasgow let's class down back in
high school in class pan cuz I was
I was just making everybody laugh I was
the one who I would throw my voice I
would throw my boys like hey didn't
thing and then you know yeah that was me
that was me that was me yeah I see that
yeah yeah let's see that yeah that's my
turn now I'm gonna ask you a question
raka okay okay okay and the time it
takes this rat to eat a piece of popcorn
name three sports played without a ball
boxing that rats gonna die he's gonna
choke on that popcorn complete Dwayne's
Twitter bio chivalrous gentleman just
add a kid just add got it just add what
I love to drink fine ah
terra-man fine thank you her mama took
you okay my question are you ready
complete Kevin's Twitter bio my name is
Kevin Hart and I am a piece of [ __ ] stop
it that's not a piece of in my in my bio
and your bio I'm gonna say I'm a piece
of [ __ ] in my bio do not say that in my
bio the kind of comedian you are
self-deprecating like that that what
makes you brilliant you know I work hard
there you go
that that's not in your body my heart
just says I work hard yes so that's like
I'm Kevin Hart I have a [ __ ]
heartbeat all right I breathe air it I'm
Dwayne the rock Johnson I drink tequila
no that's I know but at least that's fun
yeah that generally read your bio and
goes Wow [ __ ] yeah he works hard
just wet I'm Dwayne the rock Johnson
yeah I'm a grown man sometimes I drink
all right that's good
never see the point neither one of us
should get a point yes maybe we should
change
I have that okay all right vials will be
changed after the day and the time it
takes this Rhino to break his twig name
for film starring Kevin Hart okay go
ride-along
soul plane Central Intelligence your
mother how does a rhino take that long
to break it how was it working with with
Kevin Hart you know the the beauty
reserve young there's a thing there's a
thing and this thing this thing you
can't it's rich
you can't wouldn't when you get out it's
like it's like taking a let's take it
let's take a look let's say we got to
wait you're gonna pick it up nine times
out of ten you can't do a set with it
that's where we movie Jail
ah hey yo my let me give y'all my can
you get a one of the between us
alright okay this is a good one uh which
concert does Kevin say was the first
concert he attended in his life you got
to know this one let's break it down
comedy yeah got it yep you went to see
comedian or was it a group no it was
group a group it was a group kings
economy Sesame Street oh nice
when when you were a kid no I was like
18 1780 cool cool thing no need the
judges I'm not judging something I
thought was cool to do man at a time it
takes this pug to wake up name three
things beginning with J go all right
Jumanji jokes
Jupiter Oh what did she just get a dog
the smell make urine sniffing ass oh no
one was like working with the that's
what I can't even do yeah finally going
DJ I found a road Tobin looking at those
questions you probably realize how
uninteresting you are completely Wow in
2000 which rapper did Duane collaborate
with on the single it doesn't matter
is that the song is that are you singing
a song yeah it doesn't matter name of
the song where's that from it doesn't
matter I was dead what this is why I say
it like that who is that that is that
that's like iconic [ __ ] Oprah that
doesn't matter Lexy
well Oprah does that when she goes out
of cars it doesn't matter who you are
you get a car you get a car you get a
car I don't do that but she doesn't
that's not that's not no no no no no no
it doesn't matter if you like ice cream
you're gonna oh no Wyclef remember you
know right
oh and the time it takes this dog to
squeeze through the wall name three
American football teams go the paid paid
old on Ravens Eagles Jaguars Dwayne went
to the University of Miami what did he
study while he was there study what
would you stay tight like as in educate
yourself as in yes I'm like um I tried
to get better it's real my textbooks and
Wow um cars changing batteries and cars
it's gotta be uh if it's a subject um
alright [ __ ] let's take a crack in
communications good communication was a
good choice that's not it no no no I
wanted to work for the CIA
thank God that didn't what's that
supposed to mean just come be a great
agent with the agency and we'd be in
trouble I said criminology I've been
talking with with Kevin Hart no it's
good yeah yeah I've been talking with
the big guy yeah have you talked with
the big guys been great I mean he's
doing a lot of things that's what we do
we just do big things around here what
we did as a production you you want to
grow I mean you got two guys who just
they want they want the warts it's hard
for people to understand the world okay
it's hard for people to understand the
world but you've got two guys who just
support each other that's the thing he's
gonna thank you Mexico you guys always
have a very good [ __ ] thing me I'll
do a good job guys yeah
[Applause]
I don't know like that makes that noise
octopus night